se i ragazzi se consumato iceberg che è
da un po che non lo faccio ogni tot
riprendiamo a vedere se riesco a non far
pagare in questa partita
johnny one giorno ragazzi tutto a posto
italia c'è nel senso che io in questo
punto ciò così quando sto registrando
video ecco aspetta stessa cosa sono
riusciti a chiudere la botta un attimo
prima esplosione abolita roba non
mangiano breve nessuno andate a cagare
quanto dove vuoi vincere l'asta partita
maledizione
io non vinco io ho vinto ho vinta sics
ii una volta con pietro cioè questa dice
tutta quindi questo che facciamo
aggiungere al nostro domani cece
giuseppe conto ha detto che volete stare
a casa
ma come sta bussando di esistenza la
botta dobbiamo provare aprile potrebbe
se una buona notizia
apri pronto testimoni di geova
ciao a tutti e bottiglie d'acqua
pazzesco era la promozione della della
sant'anna fantastico ieri c'era bisogno
di esercizio fisico farli andare a
correre fuori una landa desolata se non
un po azzardato ma potrebbe invece
giocare nei rifugi ad acchiappare
ovviamente no perché se non rompete le
bottiglie d'acqua che state fermi
metteteli il culo attaccato asta se
diamo allora fate schifo non c'è più
spazio per le attività simili esatto
gioca playstation fai i giochi in
simulator fai quello che vuoi non lo so
questo oggi mangiano tutti e bevono
tutti ragazzi sperano sia morto nessuno
perfetto mangiate la sette giorni tutto
a posto raga acqua e cibo for everyone e
già tutte le provviste vanno a farsi
benedire
peraltro abbia seguito i rumori sospetti
mi ha detto laporta stati ha riaperto e
trovando invece in pelle non riportano
inizio e noi ne siamo certi sia per noi
apriamo sì tanto c'è il gatto il buon
sharipov che da un botto che non vedo
vediamo quanto figura nel rifugio non è
carico e chieda scusa all'intera riceve
il tratto della zuppa ma era scaduta da
secoli non ci siamo non ci sentiamo il
dovere a cui noi hanno passato la
mattina dico per il secchione
ma non è che vi siete ammalati l'ammazzo
no posso malattia
ok sembra nato mio figlio perché hanno
usato a solo annusato della zuppa quindi
a posto team iva il ko
cosa vuoi portare fuori cosa che cosa
vuoi portarti niente non ti porti niente
perché non ho niente vai vai a cercare
cose torna vittorioso figlio mio
forza l'esercito sta dando a prenderci
la sua aspettare con pazienza questo
lato la voce noiosa e stato molto chiaro
su questo punto i soccorsi sono arrivati
vabbè tanto è da una vita che lo dicono
arrivati in una volta sola che ero con
pietro
il piano per il culo madonna mio figlio
non tornerà mai dalla landa desolata mai
è morto mio figlio è morto e poi a
partecipare bassissima salve però
guadagnato uno scarafaggio
porca vacca ragazzi porca vacca deve
tornare team in tutto sto casino se non
casinò ve lo dico già pronto ma chi è
che chi è che chi è che sta bussando
alla porta e casinò
qua non so se già dato da bere un gruppo
di dottori ha bussato alla porta
chiedendo le provviste per rifornire i
loro kit medici non abbiamo dovuto della
loro buona fede ma chi se ne frega
andate a cagare non sopravvivere già c'è
poca acqua
morite mio figlio è morto sono convinto
che broi e questo nemmeno medici veri
non darebbe un bel niente a questi
furfanti e suadente che l'avevo detto io
comunque ricordate i ragazzi il cibo gli
sette giorni quindi 78 c21e prossimo
invece per quanto riguarda l'acqua ogni
3 caricamento deve essere buono abbiamo
pensato fosse una buona idea di
superficie l'appena bene riuscire
d'occhi animaleschi assi questo cioè c'è
un po la bestia fuori dalla porta
non fate niente che vede la porta ovvero
che non è in treno faccio un casino
dubito timi tesoro ti sei portato bravo
l'atrio dell'albergo era in uno stato
deplorevole ma siamo riusciti a trovare
non siamo riusciti a tra le molte cose a
parte un boscaiolo molto pelosa
decisamente morto nelle mani teneva
ancora un'ascia ok
teoricamente posso mandare qualcun altro
di spedizione dovrebbe essere quel
qualcun altro mary jane non scherzo che
quella che fa più schifo in spedizione
devo mandare il mio ma darà il padre
perché se non mando lui spedizione non
torna nessuno perché mary jane non l'ho
mai vista tornare mai
cioè è veramente raro che torni quindi
devo assolutamente mandar lui quindi vai
con un'ascia torna e porta roba portale
porta quello che vuoi giorno 18 acqua
everyone ne ho abbastanza di a
coordinare insapore pure ma ne ho
contate e pure bravo a una tazza di
caffè vero caffè americano ma andate a
cagare acqua sporca quello non ti fa
abbassare la stanchezza almeno se le
baby cinque tazze esatto ma dove lo
troveremo nadal è giornata per risate
preferito la lares e cioè si trovava un
paio di isolati da qua forse qualcuno
dovrebbe intraprendere una missione per
il caffè ma che vai tu che cazzo ne so
io era dolores ora mary jane o dolore
superbike ama la tv se ne frega
la malata no a posto così trovato e
tordo caffè fantastiche aver trovato una
caraffa piena di caffè freddo il sapore
strano e non abbiamo né zucchero nel
latte ma va bene così
la miglioramento rispetto all'acqua
diamo da mangiare a tutti un giorno
prima ma sì un giorno prima avete bevuto
non cagato murghab ci arriva lista della
bandiera l'esercito ha inviato un
comunicato radio
armiamoci di torce rimaniamo pronti a
segnare la nostra presenza loro veicolo
questa sera per un sera il quartiere se
vedranno riuscire a torcia sapranno dove
trovarci minchia veramente potrei
rischiare di vincere
rondo siete l'esercito rno a vodafone ma
come tutto sta andando come previsto
concerto buttato al cesso si è spenta
certo portante siamo decide ripararla
prima quando ero ha fatto la sua
comparsa se con quei sicuri che però da
ci abbia visti ma vedremo se ci verranno
a prendere timide e mangiare qualcosa
oggi o mai più
ma ha mangiato ieri è tornato il padre
ti prego dimmi che non siamo ha dato di
milano siena mandato di micron sembrato
è ammalato punta a una merda però ho un
sacco di acqua è tornato sano e salvo
robe bicchia però mancano i kit da
allora la sopravvivenza ci sono mancano
i kit medici perché il padre sta morendo
e gli serve assolutamente bere e
mangiare tutti ragazzi bere mangiare
tutti ricominciamo potremo andare
qualcuno fuori e qualcuno potrebbe
essere mary jane solo per dare meno cibo
agli altri effettivamente perché è tutto
uno spreco di cibo e di acqua
quindi io butterei qualcuno dei fori
fatto per bene
mio figlio ha qualche problema mio
figlio è richard htt da piccolo comunque
qualcuno sta cercando di scassinare la
botola
non fate niente tanto che potete
difendere anche da dentro pranzo giorno
[Musica]
cazzo
praga oddio no
vi prego salvateci ci hanno rubato tutto
non siamo riusciti a respingere gli
aggressori hanno preso d'assalto rifugio
hanno avuto pietà di noi ma non delle
nostre provviste io non gli ho respinti
perché ho detto vabbè ma lascia la puoi
usare anche dopo mentre entrano no
mentre giocava nel rifugio carico ha
trovato nasca una scatoletta di legno
che era nascosta letta alcuni mattoni
smos e al suo interno c'erano alcuni
cimeli inutile nella chiamata in
all'insetticida beh a posto abbiamo un
insetticida
buon appetito ragazzi ci hanno rubato
tutto l'ultimo degli ultimi giorni sono
che sta arrivando veramente l'esercito
non mi è mai successa sta roba che
rubassero tutto abbiamo poche provviste
beh non avete non è che non avete più
vicino c'è un piccolo gruppo di
sopravvissuti por vai correre e cori dal
gruppo di sopravvissuti taranto e ciao
ciao morti tutti morti tutti di fame di
sete di cibo tutto timi è sparito va
bene a me abbiamo siamo andati abbiamo
preso e siamo tornati
siamo certi che se la caverà come tema
la vita sia assolutamente abbiamo
portato una valigetta questo casino
tutti morti tutti morti morti morti
morti perché ci hanno rubato le
provviste io voglio morire perché dai
quello scassina la porta arrivi con
l'ascia maria e va via
prevede sempre 100 ragazzi ricordatevi
se qualcuno bussa alla porta apportate
un'ascia perché non si sa mai
penso che questa fosse meno probabile
dell'esercito sta cosa che è successa
non mi è mai successa che poi io avrei
cliccato sì ho detto no perché detto va
bene a lasciarla ai anche dentro i
furgoni ragusis entra
erano in 26 che ha tutto tutto una
crociera c'erano i gangster tutti
società anche adac polo gang entrata va
beh spero che sia piaciuto iscritti al
canale schiacciate tasto mi piace e ci
diamo più possibilità di far provare
tutto dei ragazzi
[Musica]